why do so many writers say that
outlining prevents them from being
creative oh I think that I think a lot
of writers feel like if they outline to
in too detailed of a manner it will sort
of force them into a corner when they're
writing right they'll have it too
planned out it'll take the creativity
out of it it'll take that sort of
spontaneity out of their creative
process or something like that
um I I guess that's my that's my best
guess that's why some writers think that
um that outlining is stifling but I
actually think that outlining the the
process of outlining your story like
breaking your story and and forming the
outline can be the creative process
right like that sort of creative process
that you look for when you're writing of
Discovery and you know coming up with
new ideas by kind of juxtaposing things
that you didn't expect or whatever you
can do that in the outlining process
itself right and kind of have all of
those Sparks of inspiration and
creativity while you're working in that
in that format instead of in on the page
if that makes sense
do you get a lot of pushback from
writers who don't want to outline
um not a ton I you know I think it's
probably 50 50 in terms of writers who
liked outline or at least have learned
that it's more helpful than than uh
painful for them right and so there are
you know plenty of writers who Embrace
outlining as part of their process
um and they're but then there are also
writers who
um either you know feel like it's too
stifling or don't really have a good
process and so they
stay away from outlining or avoid it
just because they don't really
have like a set of steps that they can
go through that's sort of reliably helps
them plan out their story right some
writers consider themselves very
intuitive writers and they're
um you know their their pantsers instead
of plotters
um I don't think that even those writers
that consider themselves sort of you
know intuitive writers I don't think
that I get a lot of pushback from them
um usually those writers if they've been
through a few writing projects and it's
been a struggle to get all the way
through because they haven't had a map
to kind of guide them through it an
outline
um they are usually not pushing back on
needing an outline they're coming to me
because they're like okay I don't really
love the outlining process but I feel
like I need one in order to help me get
through the draft right so more than
anything they're coming to me and saying
like I want to learn a little bit about
outlining that I can maybe incorporate
into my more free-form process but that
will give me some structure to kind of
help me get through the writing you know
and you think when we tell a writer that
this outlining is so much part of the
process and really if you don't have one
it's like building a house without a
good set of sort of blueprints
um that it's like pulling back this this
magical curtain that they thought it was
just going to be this free-flowing thing
and it's almost disappointing in some
way
um I hope it's not disappointing
um but uh yeah I think that
maybe maybe coming up with a story in
the outlining process to some writers
feels like it's
um it's going to be too Technical and
too rigid right
um but but if you you know actually
start because outlining can mean so many
different things to so many different
writers right so if you actually start
kind of working through different steps
different tools different you know types
of processes to get get through an
outline you'll see that it's really
adaptable it's you know the process of
outlining is kind of whatever you make
of it it's whatever helps you prepare to
write whatever it is you're writing so I
don't know I don't think it's um I don't
think it's necessarily like
disappointing to writers but I think
that it's uh maybe eye-opening like they
they figure out kind of what outlining
really is and and what it is is specific
to them it's like whatever's going to
help you
plan enough that you have that kind of
you know structure to get through
writing your draft
burden or is
part of the process
part of the process for sure
um
I hope that writers don't think of it as
a burden
um because I actually think that the
outlining process is where a lot of the
fun and creativity can happen
um it's where you have the joy of sort
of you know exploring and discovering
your story and figuring out a lot of the
fun stuff about it so I hope it doesn't
feel like a burden
um I do think that whatever sort of prep
you do for your story is part of your
own personal process and you know
whether you are a very detailed outliner
or more of just a like sort of broad
broad Strokes I got to figure out kind
of the general shape of my story I
consider all of that sort of the
pre-writing or outlining process so
whatever it is for you is is part of the
process for you you know why is it hard
for writers who think they have a great
idea to actually start writing their
ideas down and begin the writing process
it's a good question I'm sure there are
a lot of different answers to this
question just depending on the writer
um I think part of it is probably fear
right and that fear can also be
different for different writers too
before you write anything down I think
an idea Can Feel Complete and perfect in
your head and then when you sit down to
start actually breaking it down or
planning it you can it can be a little
um surprising at how little you actually
know about the idea before you started
to try to write it down it felt very
complete and perfect and then when you
start to write it sometimes it it can or
you know start to plan it it can feel
like Oh I thought I had more of this
figured out or I thought this idea was a
little bit more solid or complete you
know so I think that can be scary and
can discourage people from beginning the
process because they feel like they want
to figure out more of it in their head
still before they start putting anything
on paper
I actually think putting it on paper is
kind of what helps you work through that
and and helps you figure out your story
um so I would encourage people to go
ahead and just start but um but yeah I
think it's probably fear you know
something can feel very
um solid and makes sense before you have
to articulate it and then when you try
to articulate it it ends up you know
sort of showing the holes in it so
do you think it's because a lot of uh
writers or quote-unquote artists in
general live in their heads so much and
and it feels so real to them the story
and then when you actually say okay
let's actually see it on the and and
then it's it's you're you're asking them
to be in reality yeah I'm sure that
there is truth to that because so many
writers are you know living in their
imaginations a lot of the time
um I also think that you know a lot of
times when we get inspired by a story
idea we get really excited about it what
we're thinking about most of the time is
that sort of Act One setup portion of it
it's like the interesting situation that
sort of funny what if or what it you
know how would this happen or why would
this happen
um and then when you sit down to kind of
figure out the whole story you realize
oh the part that got me so excited and
there's nothing wrong with it at all but
the the part that gets us excited is
that setup it's that situation right
that interesting what if and then the
rest of the story is the part that you
still have to figure out
um so I think that that you know it's
not that you it's not that you came up
with an idea that you thought was better
than it actually is it's that you came
up with an idea that you have only
partially figured out as is natural
right because you came up with that part
first and then the work of it is sort of
figuring out the rest of the story The
the journey that your character is going
to go on so
right I think that's what I was feeling
I just didn't know how to put it into
words and I think that that was that's
it it's that's like the the setup is so
vivid in our minds but then actually
having it pay off and there'd be an arc
yes and and a resolution to it I think
that's yeah yeah yeah because that's
usually that's that spark of inspiration
is we get inspired by that like oh
wouldn't it be funny if this happened or
wouldn't it be like dramatic or scary if
you know this happened
um and that's all that act one setup
stuff so
what is your argument for writers to
learn an outlining process that works
for them hmm my argument for it uh let's
see well I mean I I think that having a
process will help you right having
something to fall back on when you feel
stuck or you feel frustrated or you feel
like I thought I had the story all
figured out and now I'm realizing it's
only the beginning
um having a process that you have sort
of worked through before you know that
it works for you or at least you know
that you have some tools to draw on that
can help you get unstuck I think that's
helpful helpful for any writer right
um and you know no matter your
experience level I think with every
project there's going to be a point
where you do sort of get stuck or you
feel frustrated or it's not going as
well as you wanted it to or you thought
it would
um so just having that sort of tool kit
you know which is what I think of as a
as an outlining process I think of it as
just a toolkit a bunch of tools that you
you know how to use and you can draw on
them when you need them to kind of help
you keep progressing through the through
the process you know
but say I hire you and I have this great
screenplay and I just know this is going
to be this is going to transform
people's lives once it's on the screen
and I keep showing you draft after draft
and your note to me is I think we need
an outline and I'm the stubborn writer
and I say no it's going to ruin it and I
you know what what's a tough love way to
sort of be my accountability partner and
say I really think we need to go back
and and flesh this out more yeah that's
I mean that's a good question and I and
I have worked with writers who who were
a little bit resistant to you know
making big changes or or something like
that after a few drafts most writers
feel like okay I'm tired of of working
through the whole draft right so I think
the best argument for outlining if
you're in that situation is like you can
work on the story in an outline form
which is much smaller and shorter and
easier to manage than working on your
entire draft right trying to go into
your screenplay pages and make changes
sometimes is very difficult right it's
you're you're adjusting things kind of
in the in the living document of it
versus if you make an outline even of an
existing draft make your changes in that
document that's like you know looking at
the skeleton of the screenplay so you
can move things around more easily
you're not looking at completed scenes
that you've already fallen in love with
or lines of dialogue that you love and
you don't want to change you're looking
at it from a little bit more uh I think
maybe of an objective point of view
um you're looking less at the sort of
you know on the page stuff and looking
at the skeleton of your story which I
think helps people kind of you know have
some perspective on it and be able to
see what's not working and make changes
without getting sort of bogged down in
in all the stuff that all the work
they've already put into it that they
don't want to redo you know
I love that so fatigue I like you use
that word and so if you're seeing a
fatigued writer and let's suppose I'm
this again I'm resistant no Neil we've
got to do it this way it's fantastic and
then you're seeing the fatigue on this
side that that does sound interesting
then let's look at it and let's try to
actually just shorten it down and then
work out the problems yeah and a lot of
times when I'm working with writers I
will actually outline I will make an
outline from their draft so that I can
talk about it in a way that is you know
has that perspective and I can say okay
so if we look at act one and see here
are all the scenes you know this is this
is the issue that we're kind of trying
to address let's look at which scenes
that might be happening in or which
scenes might be missing that so we're
not getting the information we need or
or whatever the the specific issue is
you know oh I love that it's almost the
analogy of let's suppose I have this
messy closet and I can't find anything
in it and then you come and you're this
organizer and you're like okay let's put
all of the blouses you know and I like
that that's beautiful that's a good
analogy yeah
but this somebody that that has that
skill of being able to see the big
picture and yeah yeah and I do think too
you know we get so attached to the
things that we're writing our scripts
and um our projects and everything that
I think that sometimes it's easier to
have me outline it from their draft
versus for a couple of reasons like
sometimes writers because they've
written a whole draft they're like well
I don't want to go back and outline it
now I don't want to make an outline from
the thing I've already written right
like what good is that gonna do me
um so sometimes they're resistant to do
it at all but I also think that
sometimes it's easier for me to do it
again because I'm I'm objectively
looking at the script so I can look at
the scene and say well here's what I'm
getting from the scene that's what I'm
going to write down in the outline
versus you know if you're very close to
your story you know what you were trying
to get across in that scene and so you
might outline it differently than I
would as well right so sometimes it's
helpful I think if I do the outline or
if we compare outlines and then we can
see kind of where's the discrepancy here
oh this is what that scene was meant to
do from your point of view and here's
what I think it's actually doing you
know
why do you say that most movie ideas are
very simple well I think movies tend to
be based on really simple stories one of
the things that newer writers can end up
doing without realizing it is over
complicating their stories right because
they feel like especially if they start
writing without a solid outline and they
kind of get stuck they feel like oh I
have to add more complications to give
me more story to write and they'll end
up making things overly complex where
you know the movies that we tend to see
are pretty straightforward stories
they're you know a concise setup some
good escalations in the middle and then
wrap it up in the end and it's the
execution that makes things entertaining
and interesting right so it's it's not
that we need very complex stories in
movies a lot of times overly complex
stories will be kind of hard to follow a
little bit bloated you know it'll be
hard to kind of really go deep in a
character's experience in a story that
has too many complications or too many
characters
whereas typically in movies what we see
is like you know one person pursuing one
thing and what's interesting or
entertaining about it is the way that
that sort of is executed
um the interesting cinematic you know
cool stuff that happens along that
Journey which is actually a pretty
simple Journey but it allows us the kind
of space to dive into how that character
is transforming the emotional experience
of it and kind of like the the you know
cool cinematic stuff that happens along
the way
does a simple idea mean a boring
screenplay no I I don't think so um I
think most if you look at most movies
it's actually a very simple storyline
right it's a it's a pretty
straightforward you know one person
trying to achieve one thing
I think a lot of times newer writers
maybe worry that their stories are too
simple and that will make them boring
but
if you have a simple story that just
gives you a a nice sturdy framework to
tell your story and then it gives you
the sort of space and the freedom to
find the entertaining moments and cool
stuff in the execution of that story if
that makes sense right and no you've
said and I don't know if it was it was
in the book or it's in an interview that
the cliche of sort of like the the
pretty but doesn't know it or the hot
mess that sort of is rescued you know
right that that's been done so much and
I agree
um but what if somebody really needs to
stick to the rom-com where High School
reunion and best friends getting married
and does anybody object but they want to
do the next Memento or they want to do
the next crash something that takes a
little more putting together and you
guide them and say maybe you're not
totally ready for that yet yeah I think
that that is a challenge right
um you know some there are some stories
that are
I don't know if I would call them more
complex but the the execution of them is
more advanced right like crashes
intersecting storylines kind of all put
together within the structure of a
feature film
um I would call that like in a you know
sort of advanced craft kind of movie
right
um so I don't think that that's uh
necessarily an overly complicated story
at all and there definitely are newer
writers who who love movies like that
and who want to write something like
that and that's what's inspiring them
and sort of getting them in front of the
computer to write it uh I certainly
wouldn't discourage them I do think that
um you know when you're learning it's
going to be easier to learn and to to
sort of understand to wrap your brain
around like how to put a screenplay
together if you work with a simpler
story or a more
um sort of straightforward mainstream
kind of story with one main character
who's sort of pursuing one main goal in
the story that'll be easier just to
learn on
um if that makes sense like when you're
learning to drive a car you know if you
learn on an automatic that's a little
bit easier than like learning how to
shift and learning how to drive at the
same time not that it can't be done but
it just might take a little bit longer
right it might take a little more
patience
um so so yeah I think that if you're if
you have the desire to write something
like crash or like memento
if you are willing to be patient with
yourself and give yourself the time to
sort of figure out how to write that
particular screenplay then great you
know different people are motivated by
different things so if that's what's
going to get you to show up and keep
trying and keep learning your craft then
go for it
um it just know that it might be a
longer process because you're sort of
learning lots of different skill sets at
the same time and learning how to write
a screenplay is already a bunch of
different skill sets you know sort of
put together
um so that's just adding a little bit
more to your plate but it it can be done
for sure
sure I love that analogy so the driving
the car so it's like learning to drive
in your dad's old Station Wagon versus
some sporty little foreign model with a
clutch on a hill right right exactly and
you've never driven before and you have
all these people behind you honking so
yeah that that makes sense yeah yeah but
if you're in that situation I mean if
that's what um sort of inspires you to
learn how to drive right then then go
for it and just know that you have
you're going to have to be you know sort
of gentle on yourself and and patient
with yourself because it's it's probably
going to be
you know frustrating but if you love the
story that's okay you might have the
patience to kind of get through that
right
do you think audiences though really
resonate more with simple stories or no
as long as it's a well-told story yeah I
think as long as it's a well-told story
um I think simple stories
um the the benefit that that maybe they
offer to audiences and to writers too is
that they you know when I say A Simple
Story I mean sort of like the the plot
framework is fairly straightforward
um and
what you're what you're able to bring to
that as a writer is finding new ways
that maybe the you know sort of tropes
that we expect from the genre those
things are executed in a new interesting
entertaining you know cinematic sort of
way right so you're bringing your you're
not you're not writing the boring
screenplay
um just to make it easy for yourself
you're you're choosing a story that
gives you a framework that is easy to
wrap your brain around so that you can
bring the creativity to it and add the
entertaining stuff on top of it and then
the other benefit is that you know with
a with a somewhat um straightforward
plot
um I don't want to say it's too
straightforward but if with a simple
plot framework that allows you to then
you know come up with the cool reversals
and interesting twists and turns and all
that stuff
um the other thing that you can that
that gives you is sort of the space and
the freedom to develop the character
more right because if you are taking
less time time to explain the way the
plot is working or why you know
complications are happening the way they
are it gives you room for the characters
to feel things and to interact with each
other and to transform and be you know
be affected by what they're going
through and it gives you kind of some
space for us to have that experience
along with the character if that makes
sense it does and I know we've talked
about bridesmaids before and you use it
as an example in the book and what seems
like a simple story when you actually
put these relationship Dynamics it's
actually much more complicated and yeah
very interesting yeah and that's a good
example I think that bridesmaids is a
simple story right it's a very clear
story framework that that they're
working within but they have all these
lovely lovely funny you know set pieces
that are inventive that we haven't seen
before right so that's in the execution
that they're able to kind of you know
they have this sturdy Foundation that
they're building on top of but it gives
them the freedom to do really fun funny
entertaining things and we also because
the plot framework is so sturdy and easy
for us to kind of understand what's
happening
um you know you get that character that
is nicely developed over the entire
movie which you know you might not
expect that in a broad comedy right but
there's a lot of feeling there too she's
really going through something in that
story so yeah there's a lot of levels
and and it's about to uh the outward
appearances yeah and and trying to kind
of keep up with friendships and your
peer group and stuff and and so yeah
it's a movie that when I first heard
about it I was like yeah that's not for
me and everybody was like oh you got to
see bridesmaids I'm like no and then I
finally saw it and I'm like why was I
resistant to it because it's excellent
yeah that's one of those I can watch
over and over again because it's so
entertaining and there is so much sort
of genuine you know Humanity in it as
well so
if a writer has three ideas how do they
know which one to choose oh well
um I think it depends on sort of what
they want out of the writing project
right so there I think there are a few
criteria you can look to and it's a
really personal decision I also think
you don't ever have to throw an idea
away if you have three that you want to
write you know that means you're really
just choosing which one you're going to
write next and then you can always have
the other two on Deck right
um I personally think that you should
you know sort of gauge the concept and
make sure that each idea you're weighing
is a strong enough idea to be a
screenplay that's the first thing
um but if all that's equal
um I think you you should look at what
you want to get out of the out of the
project so is it helping you you know
learn a new skill in your in your
writing kind of toolkit is it um helping
you advance your career in a particular
way is it you know filling out your
portfolio of writing samples
um so that is helpful to to kind of
gauge what do I want this to do for me
so that you're not you know no writing
is wasted it's not wasted time but so
that you're getting the most out of of
the project that you're going to write
um and then also if you know the ending
I think that that's very helpful
um because that you know
sometimes if you start a writing project
without knowing the ending
that can be a longer more frustrating
process to to outline that but if you
kind of you know how this story ends the
outlining of it the figuring out kind of
how the the plot progresses all the
steps in the plot and everything that's
a little bit easier because you know
what destination you're headed towards
so that's interesting when you said that
you've you've actually outlined four
people once you see their finished
script if you see someone who's hung up
on the ending do you get them to that
point and then say okay now I mean I
realize you're not figuring out the
ending for them but do do you outline up
until that point and then maybe that
helps them through it well if I'm if I'm
making an outline from a finished draft
that someone's you know given me to read
um I outline exactly what they have in
the draft so if their ending isn't
working or if it isn't complete
um and I have read scripts like that I
will outline exactly what they have and
then we'll talk about you know what's
missing here is it is that the ending is
totally gone and you need to figure out
what that is or is it just that you know
you've you've sort of wrapped up the
plot but it's not it's really not
complete or you know resolving things as
it needs to so I mean that's kind of
um just a normal a normal day in in kind
of doing the script consults is lot of
times the ending needs work so we'll
just talk about like how can we
strengthen that sure but that sounds
really helpful just again as it's easier
for someone to come in and organize
someone's space than if you have all
these personal mementos and like oh I
can't get rid of this I can't get rid of
that oh my grandmother gave me this but
if the organizer comes in and says how
about we put this over here it yeah it
sounds like it's much easier yeah and I
think that I think that that's such a
good analogy because that is probably
what it feels like as well you know if
you've written a draft and you're like
here are the scenes that I love and I
want them to be in there but you know
something about it isn't working there
is that feeling of like I'm attached to
these things but I don't know how to
organize them in a way that they need to
in order for it to kind of like make
sense for everyone else as well you know
sure yeah sure and then you open the
closet door everything falls yes and
hence the screenplay might be really
jumbled and if we put it if we make
sense to the to the the viewer or the
reader yeah yeah and when when I go in
there it's like you know I can sort of
outline based on what they already have
have and then we can talk about okay so
here's what we have so far and then
here's what the third act needs to do
like here's you know how it needs to
resolve the plot and wrap up character
Arc and all that stuff so what are we
missing and then we can kind of fill in
the holes you know
what is brain dump oh um that's just
something I'm sure other people use it
in different ways but it's something
that I think is a useful exercise to do
at the beginning of sort of your your
story breaking process you know when you
come up with an idea
um and you haven't really done much to
shape it yet I think it's really useful
to just sort of sit down and write down
everything you know about that idea
because you end up capturing stuff that
you maybe didn't realize you knew about
it or thought about it and then you also
sort of end up capturing like what you
love about that idea when you're in that
moment of still being in love with it so
that later on when you're writing the
script and you inevitably get to that
frustrating part where you get stuck or
you don't know what happens next and you
you know are feeling like why did I
start writing this you can kind of go
back to that brain dump and remember
like what made me fall in love with this
idea to begin with or what was it about
this idea that you know in spite hired
me how did I want people to feel
what were my hopes and aspirations for
this project you know before I went down
started Down The Long Road of actually
writing it so yeah
so if I have let's say a notebook
um and it's my idea for this movie or
this character I'm just kind of like
this is my notebook where I'm going to
put The Good the Bad and the Ugly about
this character the story anything I can
think of yeah um and I think it's
probably different for every project and
for every writer like what comes to mind
I think it's useful to give yourself a
little bit of structure you know some
parameters around the brain dump but
really it should be whatever you know
about your your project at that point in
time so I just think you know write down
anything that um where the idea came
from anything that inspires you about
the idea or how do you see this finished
movie like what other movies would it
would would it be like
um what's the soundtrack sound like are
there any songs that give you that
feeling that you want the movie to have
talking about characters for sure like
who's the main character if you know
that what's that character like
uh what kind of relationships does that
character have who are the people in his
or her life
um you know kind of anything that you
sort of come to the table with when
you're just getting you know inspired by
that idea like just starting to sort of
gather everything that you know about it
that you're going to start shaping into
the story eventually like because you
know at the beginning it's like you have
a jumble of ideas I think you have oh
this would be a great scene or you know
oh I think it ends like this maybe with
this final shot I don't know how we get
there but it's them riding off into the
sunset or
um you know I I don't know who this
character is but I think that there's a
guy who you know had this background or
has this you know affectation and I
wonder how he got to be that way and so
it's just a it's just a way for you to
start to gather kind of like all of
those little tidbits that you think
might belong to this story put them all
in one place so that you don't have that
that feeling of like you know that
nervous feeling of like I'm gonna forget
this idea and I I don't know where it
goes yet and so you're all stressed out
about trying to work it into the story
you can put it all in one place and just
hold it there so that as you're working
through kind of that development process
you can always go back to it and
reference it come up with those ideas
that you had at one time that maybe
you'd forgotten about so
so let's suppose
um I was Eric Roth and I was thought of
this idea for this Forrest Gump
character or based on a book whatever
and and I thought okay here's my here's
my notebook with forest in it and so
southern town
um loving mom uh you know definitely uh
health problems with with his legs
different things and then meets Jenny
um meets Bubba all these different
things meets Captain Dan you know you
know different fights different things
and his goal of being sort of this just
this theme through his life of of being
in like these interesting places at the
right time and helping people he's
almost like a helper yeah um and so
um I'm just kind of like getting it out
this is Forest this is there wasn't
really anything bad about him but these
are some of the things that that make up
this Forest character yeah and hopefully
you know if you're working on that
project or you were inspired enough to
kind of sit down and start to gather
your thoughts hopefully there's
something about who that character is
that you really like right or that
interests you at least and so so those
are the things that I think you should
focus on because those are going to be
the things that sort of help you later
on in the story you know like
um having those touchstones of like oh
yeah I remember I really wanted this
character to have this particular
feeling or to maybe have this particular
Arc to learn this lesson across this
story
um so yeah I I don't even know
um if you I guess if you know that much
about your story it's great and write it
all down but you don't even have to try
to you know shape it in the brain dump
process I think
um
I wouldn't put pressure on yourself to
try to come up with like oh this is
First Act stuff and this is you know
where the story goes from there it's
just kind of whatever you know whatever
Sparks your interest when you think
about that particular idea
um and I always like the the sort of
prompts or questions you ask yourself
about like
what do how do I see this in its
finished form even if it's not specifics
but it's like how do I want people to
feel when they see it or you know what
does the soundtrack sound like is a good
one because it's like What feelings does
it give you when you hear the you know
music or what music makes you think of
this idea or make you feel the way this
idea makes you feel
um and then I also one other thing that
I think is really helpful to do in the
kind of brain dump process is think
about what the story means to you
um because that helps you start to
narrow in on the theme of the story
which I think is one of those things
that like really intimidates a lot of
writers it feels like oh I have to come
up with some big profound statement
um but really you're just trying to come
up with like the mean what does it mean
to you right like what's the sort of
takeaway message or you know big idea
that this story imparts and that can be
really daunting and intimidating so if
you do it in the brain dump process
where you're just sort of free-flowing
and brainstorming
um it gives you kind of a pressure free
and environment to kind of think about
like what does the story mean like what
kind of lesson would this character
learn or what kind of lesson could this
experience teach someone you know
um and what's the story about for me
like what does it what does it sort of
mean to me you know inside that I that I
kind of want to get at or explore in the
story
okay so I wouldn't necessarily know
maybe all of these things when I
mentioned Lieutenant Dan and these
things I would just know that it's a
character maybe the odds were kind of
stacked against him but he didn't really
have a mean streak in him he didn't need
to get revenge on people yeah or maybe
what have been done to him or or he was
still just a kind-hearted guy yeah and I
think maybe if you were developing that
story idea right
um in the brain dump process you might
not know the specifics about those other
characters but you might say okay I have
this main character that I'm really
interested in I think his name's Forrest
Gump and he's this type of guy right
he's a he's such a kind person he
doesn't have a mean bone in his body and
the kinds of people that he could run
into that would create conflict and help
him kind of move through the story might
be you know someone who he's in love
with who doesn't reciprocate right and
so he has to contend with that set of
emotions
um maybe he has kind of a mentor
character that he meets in the unlikely
place of in the in the military it's
been a long time since I saw so I don't
remember if uh Dan is the mentor but
maybe he meets somebody who's very Gruff
and sort of the opposite of him
personality wise right uh maybe he meets
Bubba who in some ways is similar like
sort of innocent and kind of sees the
world in a particular way and so by
pairing up with that person you know
these are the kinds of things that he
might experience or lessons that he
might learn or situations he might find
himself in you know
you believe most movies can come down to
three words who wants what yeah I think
that that's kind of the the basic nut of
of any movie right is uh you have a main
character who is trying to achieve
something because if you don't have
those basic elements and that's not the
whole story obviously but if you don't
have those basic elements then then
really what is the story you don't have
a character to sort of be our vehicle
through a series of events and you don't
have anything propelling them forward or
driving them forward if they're not
trying to achieve something you know
so if we just think we have this
interesting character and all these
different things happen to them and
these cool like conflict situations but
we don't actually know what does this
character want
is that something that we really have to
do a lot of soul searching is this are
we that character do we have to see is
this us yeah well I mean I do think the
characters should always be sort of like
our mirror or our vehicle through the
story but when I say who wants what I'm
actually talking about more sort of
external plot stuff because that's
what's going to give you that that plot
framework to tell your story right
um so really the who wants what is is
figuring out kind of what external plot
thing or what um you know destination is
your protagonist aiming toward through
this story
um knowing that helps you plan the story
and write it but it also indicating that
to the audience is really helpful
because that's how we sort of track
where we are in the story if we know
what that character is trying to achieve
that gives us like a yardstick to
measure is he succeeding or is he
failing is he making progress or is he
having setbacks right and that's the
that's that like put push-pull of like
hope and fear that we have when we're
watching the movie is we're hoping that
he makes progress and gets to his
destination but we're fearing the worst
we're fearing all these obstacles are
going to derail him or you know
um end up you know damaging him in some
way right so that's what I really mean
when I when I say who wants what we kind
of need to know
who are we watching in the story whose
story is it and what are they trying to
achieve from sort of an external plot
point of view because that gives us that
spine of the story or that through line
that we're you know tracking over the
course of the movie
what distinguishes the main character
from all other characters in a film
the writer has decided that that's the
main character no I think that
um to some degree that's that is sort of
true you decide who whose story you're
telling right and then what
um separates that character sort of in
the screenplay or for the audience is
the focus that you place on that
character you want to tell the story
from that character's
perspective or from their point of view
so that we know who we're watching
um go through this set of experiences
right so
um what separates the protagonist from
the other characters is really the focus
that you place on them and how you tell
the story sort of through the lens of
their experience does that make sense it
does yeah you know I just saw a Crazy
Stupid Love oh yeah for the first time
and it came out like 2011 or whatever
did you enjoy it I did I love and again
it was one not one that I would normally
think I would love but you know Steve
Carell he's a good guy you want to root
for him and then he kind of meets you
know the Dark Horse who then you find
out is really not that dark once you get
to know him but it you it takes you on
this this journey but a lot of the side
characters are also very complicated and
complex yeah I actually that's a great
example I just rewatched it and I had a
new appreciation for it watching it
again I remembered really liking it and
finding it funny but watching it over
again you know already knowing where the
story was going I could sort of pay a
little bit more attention to how it was
put together and you're right like it's
it's
pretty much a true like Ensemble right
because so many Side characters get
their own story lines and it has these
intersecting story lines but I do think
Steve Carell is the protagonist in that
story
um even though he like in act two we
spend a lot of time we go away from him
and kind of shift Focus to the Ryan
Gosling character right
um so just page count wise you might not
be able to decide like who is the main
character they both get their screen
time but I think what makes Steve Carell
the character the protagonist there is
that um first of all the way the story
starts right we kind of get into it
through him wanting to know kind of what
his story is and and getting on board
with his experience through the story
and then he also wraps it up in the end
he's the one who learns the lesson and
sort of brings that lesson to the group
and um you know has his transformational
experience and and we're rooting for him
I think the whole time so sure sure but
you're right there are so many because
it's not just it's not just Ryan Gosling
it's the Emma Stone character it's the
babysitter it's all these different ones
and they all have these interesting
plights that they're dealing with yeah
that the Kevin Bacon character and and
and you kind of see all of their why
they did what they did from these
different things but you still in the
end you root for the Steve Carell or at
least yeah yes viewers would yeah and
it's so it does such a good job of like
not making anyone the villain as well
which I thought was really fun
um and uh yeah and and you're right
you're right it's a great one yeah it is
it is again it's one that simple concept
but then when you take all the
relationship Dynamics and all the little
nuances and stuff it's yeah it's quite
um that one's again not probably an easy
one to write yeah were you surprised by
the the way it all comes together I was
okay yeah I definitely was I was too and
I thought that they did such a good job
of
making that feel believable but also it
you know it's big it's over the top and
you're sort of like oh it's you know
it's for humor's sake the way things
come together I don't want to spoil it
sure even though it's over a decade old
but
um we'll keep 30 years for spoilers yeah
yeah
um but it's so entertaining the way all
the story lines intersect and you sort
of don't see it coming but then it all
makes perfect sense the way it unfolds
like that so yeah what makes an
effective protagonist a few different
things
um I think that primarily they have to
be able to drive the action of the plot
right like you need a protagonist who
can take action who's willing to take
action or at least can be convinced to
take action otherwise your plot won't
advance if he's not he or she isn't
doing something to pursue their goal
um and then I also think that they're
sort of on the on the you know
character side of things there are
certain things that we look for in a
protagonist to help us get on board with
them right to kind of help us align with
them and be willing to go through the
story with them so there's you know the
the
cliche thing and the thing that writers
hate to hear is that making your
protagonist likeable right
but you know there's some truth to that
even if your character isn't likable I
think they do need to be someone that
we're willing to go along on this
journey with right so they have to be at
least engaging and entertaining enough
for us to you know like to dislike them
right sure so yeah so I think those two
you know they're kind of two prongs of
that question which is like what makes
an effective protagonist plot wise in
the story it has to be someone who can
take action and who can
um who can do things that move the plot
forward
um and then on the character development
side of things it's someone that we're
willing to go along with as they go
through this story
now I think even Stephen King said in on
writing that he didn't really like the
character of Carrie which I actually
like her but I I think that he felt that
she was compelling enough and real
enough and he saw some similarities in
his town yeah and um so yeah I mean to
invest that much time in a character
that you don't think is actually that
likable but other people saw there's
something here yeah and I think there's
you know even if you don't it's been a
while since I read Carrie but I think
even if you don't like that character
even if it's not someone that you would
hang out with he does a really good job
of creating empathy for that character
right it's like she's in a terrible
situation she's being bullied at home
and at school and you know she's awkward
and doesn't fit in and that of course is
going to even if we don't
like her in a traditional sense I think
we feel for her right and and that's
enough to get us on board and to want to
know what she's going to do next you
know
right because that's an interesting
theory of wanting to spend time with a
character that we don't actually we
maybe if we met them in real life we
wouldn't actually want to sit next to
them at the school lunch table right I
mean that's yeah no and I can think of
plenty of people that I wouldn't want to
but would I want to invest time in a
story from that character's point of
view I guess I guess because if we could
try to find something that we could
somehow connect with yeah and that's
that whole you know if you uh walk a
mile in a man's shoes right
um you'll kind of understand what
they're going through and even if you
don't agree with them you can empathize
you can understand uh actually to bring
it back to the Crazy Stupid Love I feel
like that was another thing that that
movie did really well even if so none of
those characters are unlikable right but
they did such a good job of making us
sort of care about and empathize with
Steve Carell in the beginning so that he
could then go on and become this kind of
cad-like divorce guy right so he's you
know he becomes a womanizer for a short
time in in the film and I think that
could turn a lot of people off but
because they spent time in the beginning
making us you know care about him and
feel bad for him because his wife asks
for a divorce in a crowded restaurant
out of the blue you know that gets us
that sort of earns enough of our our
like love for him that we can we know
why he's doing what he's doing and we
can watch him kind of do some not great
stuff for a little while before you know
he he brings it back around and kind of
redeems himself
and we see a lot of what he's he's kind
of being groomed by this other guy yeah
who you know he doesn't get it even from
the genes and the and that he's like you
know turn around you have a mom butt
like these are not those are not the
right jeans for you yes yeah and so yeah
he sort of reluctantly goes into that
womanizer phase right he thinks wearing
these tennis shoes and these like Dad
jeans are okay but because you know
that's not he wasn't really setting out
to be that person right so I think you
see that he's actually a good guy yeah
and he's doing it out of you know and
then when you see the other and I hope
I'm not giving a spoiler away but the
other kind of divorce dad in the bar
sipping on the drink and he doesn't
really have much of a role but you're
like oh that's kind of the next
incarnation of him like yeah you know
that's you want you want Steve Carell to
avoid becoming that guy like no matter
if you don't agree with what he's doing
now you sort of know why he's doing it
sure you feel for him you want him to
not be lonely and sad so you're kind of
willing for him to to you know be like
you said be groomed in that direction
even if it's maybe not the greatest
Direction
Naomi can you explain what a story goal
is sure
um the way I use it is really just that
it's that ultimate goal that you're sort
of your whole story is structured around
so it's the thing that your protagonist
is trying to achieve in the story
um Story Goes just the easiest way to
describe it but it's that you know it's
in Silence of the Lambs it's Clarice
trying to catch the serial killer
Buffalo Bill that's her story goal right
it's the
um plot thing that gives your entire
story its structure
is the story goal also the story engine
uh well the character's pursuit of that
story goal I think is what creates the
engine and the story right so the
protagonist trying to achieve that thing
that's what drives the story forward
it's what moves the plot
um so yeah I think the story goal is a
necessary part of that engine
can you give us examples of story goals
that work well so effective ones and
then ones that don't work well sure
um so effective story goals will have
some sort of external component right so
they can be dramatized on screen in some
way
um ineffective story goals are are
usually very internal and things that we
can't see a character taking action
toward we can't see them pursuing you
know if you're writing a movie it's it's
going to be easier to to write it to
structure it if there's some sort of
external action or at least a way for
you to show us what the character is
doing and for us to understand you know
what they're doing
um
let's see uh another thing that makes a
story goal effective is if it's
difficult enough to achieve that it will
take the whole movie to achieve right
you don't want something so easy
um or so quick that it would be achieved
in one scene or a couple of scenes
because you need it to be difficult
enough that your character
can try to you know can attempt to
achieve it over 100 minutes or whatever
and that difficulty can come from the
goal itself can be difficult or it can
also come from there's just so much
conflict in the way right that your your
characters has a hard time achieving it
because there's something or someone
trying to stop them if that does that
make sense it does so an internal goal
is hard because we unless it's a novel
we can't really tell what's going on
with the character yeah and I think that
yeah so in a something that's very
internal would be hard for you to would
probably be difficult to show on screen
right unless you can find a way to
dramatize it externally I think the
movie Short Term 12 is a good example of
that the the story goal is I think it's
sort of twofold in that movie but part
of it is
um one of the things that the character
is going through is trying to open up
right to be more open emotionally which
seems like it would be hard to to show
on screen right like how do you show
someone struggling with that
um but I think they do a good job of of
really clearly saying that it's it's if
she can talk about what happened to her
in the past I think that's how the story
goes if she can talk about what happened
to her to her in the past to her fiance
then that's kind of the you know the the
Milestone or The Benchmark that we're
looking for to indicate that she has
achieved that goal
um so yeah if it's a very internal thing
if you can find a way to indicate that
that it's being pursued and that it's
been achieved then you can you know
that's dramatizing it you can make it
and something that you can shape your
movie around
and I think some actors are are really
fantastic at showing a very closed off
person I mean William Hurt was always
great at playing somebody that you could
tell there was a lot going on inside but
he wasn't letting it out probably would
at some you know midpoint but very
contained and stifled and and so I think
there's certain certain actors that
really can play to that kind of
character yeah and I think even with
that though
um you you know something like that
something like you know if my goal is to
learn how to open up to other people
um there are great actors who can play
that struggle of like I really want to
open up but I'm afraid to or I can't
bring myself to do it even that can only
sustain I think so many scenes right and
so it has to be something that you can
also
um have other characters create conflict
with that with your protagonist you know
there has to be there have to be
obstacles in their way or opposing
forces that are making this difficult
for them as well if that if that makes
sense why do you recommend the writer to
find the goal and the method separately
oh well I think that that makes it
easier to wrap your head around your
your own story sometimes um because the
goal
the story goal that thing that the
protagonist is ultimately trying to
achieve it doesn't always imply or
indicate the kind of action that your
protagonist will be taking for most of
the movie right so I think hell or high
water is a good example of this I don't
know if you've seen that movie or we can
talk about uh Silence of the Lambs as
well whatever one yeah yeah that's okay
the the goal um sometimes is you know a
very definite end point that your
character is working towards which is
great because that gives you the
framework for your story and again you
know it gives you that um the thing that
your audience is tracking so we know
where the character is headed and that
allows us to sort of understand are they
making progress are they having setbacks
but the method I think you know is is
sort of the missing piece sometimes if
you're trying to you know break down
your story and figure out like what
happens moment to moment because
sometimes the the method is
um different or or not in implied by the
story goal itself and then a lot of
times the method is actually the
entertaining thing about the story it's
like the thing that people want to see
in the movie so I know these are
examples that that are foreign to you
but
um Silence of the Lambs like her goal is
to catch the serial killer right but the
method she's using is working with
Hannibal Lecter which is fascinating
sure that relationship is like part of
the you know the entertainment hook of
the of the movie so that's what we're
excited to watch it's also the Chase and
trying to catch that serial killer but
the the really the scenes that everyone
remembers are the ones where she's
dealing with Hannibal Lecter and sort of
going toe-to-toe with him you know
mentally and matching wits with him
right and he's baiting her and kind of
showing that he's got the upper hand
right right and he's pushing her in ways
that other people don't push her and
sort of forcing her to you know figure
out that she's she can she can handle it
and she can do it and she can you know
catch the serial killer
it's a great relationship uh another
example hell or high water just really
quickly since I brought it up
um his ultimate goal is to get the I
think it's forty thousand dollars to the
bank by such whatever the deadline is
right like that's the ultimate goal
that's what he's working towards over
the course of the movie but the method
that he's using is he has a plan to rob
a series of small town Texas Banks right
so that again that's like where the
entertainment value comes from whereas
we're watching him pull off this
carefully you know planned series of
Bank heists in small Texas towns
um that's entertaining and that if you
were writing that movie and you just
knew okay this guy needs to get this
money to the bank on time
that gives you the sort of big picture
framework but it's helpful for you the
writer to figure out like okay but
what's the what's the method what's the
more specific method that he's using to
do that because then that gives you that
act 2 action right that you can go oh
okay so he's going to do it by coming up
with this plan to Rob all these banks in
quick succession okay how's he going to
do that how many would you have to do in
a day and it it gives you more to work
with when you're coming up with the sort
of like scene by scene plotting of your
story you know
why don't we ever hear about writing a
story and coming up with a goal first
like it seems like all we do is just
want to come up with this character and
we're kind of as you say we're really in
love with like the First Act but the
actual story goal it seems like fall
short for many new writers or no do you
think so um I'm not sure I I feel like
you know you can sort of come at a story
from a lot of different ways and no
matter which angle you you come to that
idea from no matter which kind of aspect
of it inspired you to want to write it
you still have to fill in all of the
other elements in order to kind of like
have a complete thing that can work
right
um I wonder if I wonder if it feels that
way because a lot of times the story
goal feels sort of like
dry plot very you know plot specific and
dry
um and the interesting part to a lot of
writers is coming up with the the
character and the you know the person
that we're gonna go with on this journey
and coming up with those like traits
that will be fun to write
um and this maybe the story goal just
feels like a a thing that I have to
figure out that I you know don't really
I'm not inspired by I'm that could be it
well I know off camera you mentioned the
movie Hustle and we both saw it and
loved it is the story goal the Adam
Sandler goal or is the basketball
player's goal or are there several story
goals oh that's a good question um so I
when I talk about the story goal I
specifically mean the protagonist story
goal because that's really what the
movie is structured around right like
that's the the character wanting that
thing is what gives you that spine of
the story
um that sort of main through line you
might have heard it called
um so I would call the story goal in in
that movie Adam Sandler's goal which if
I were gonna articulate it I'm not sure
I remember all the details of it but it
was like to have this basketball player
be
picked up I'm not a sports person be
picked up by a team right
um did that does that sound right yeah I
think it was if I remember correctly was
he scouting out other players and
nothing was panning out either somebody
was too old or whatever and then he sees
this guy at like a street game if I
remember yeah and so it's kind of like
this unexpected he gets his wish
and now he's got to convince this guy to
come to the states yeah so so if we're
gonna kind of kind of like you know look
at that from the 40 000 foot view of of
the big picture of the story like his
story goal is the thing he's trying to
achieve by the end of it
um and in that story I would say it's it
that story goal is formed after he meets
that guy right so he
is sort of down on his luck he feels
like he's got one last chance to kind of
make his career happen we're talking
about the Adam Sandler character sure
um unexpectedly he sees this like you
know amazing Miracle of a player and
he's like that's my chance if I can get
that guy a deal and I think initially
it's a deal with the team that he works
for and then they kind of go out on
their own or something like that right
but if I can get that guy a deal then
basically my career will be saved so
that becomes his and again I wish I
remembered all the details of that story
but I think that that's kind of it that
becomes his story goal then that's the
thing that he's working towards for the
rest of the movie so the story goal
isn't something that the character
starts the movie with it's formed in act
one so they you know start the story
sort of in their normal world or their
Ordinary World or whatever
um and somewhere along the way in act
one they they form this story goal that
is the thing that drives the rest of the
movie so then pursuing that goal across
act two and into act three and then
resolving it in Acts three that's you
know that's the rest of your movie
right and if I remember correctly I
think his back is against the wall
because was the initial coach or owner
of the team like a mentor and then the
dynamic changes and now there's a a new
person at the helm yeah and he's trying
to and he's not really fitting in well
yeah so that's part of the setup that
that Ben Foster character he becomes the
team owner I think or something like
that
um yeah yeah so he's kind of like the
bratty son yes exactly so the the mentor
character Adam Sandler's Mentor
character was the owner he was the older
the patriarch of that family he passes
away and then the sun inherits it or
inherits that role anyway
um and he and Adam Sandler don't get
along so then that that like you said it
puts Adam Sandler's back up against the
wall and so then you know that's when
he's sort of in in a tough place where
he has okay I have one more chance I've
got one more chance to sort of save my
career otherwise I'm done because those
circumstances chances have changed and
then that's when he sees the basketball
player and forms that story goal
how does a writer create conflict uh
well conflict is created by two opposing
forces so if we're talking about the
main conflict in a story right that's
the protagonist trying to pursue their
goal and then whatever sort of main
force of opposition is getting in their
way so it could be
um well it can manifest in a lot of
different ways but it's whatever that
main thing is that's stopping the
protagonist or not allowing them to
easily and quickly achieve that goal
yeah and it seems like let's say with
hustle which we were talking about
earlier the Adam Sandler movie it's a
pretty clear you know idea of what that
conflict is but if you look at let's say
Forrest Gump an older version of a movie
um it's not actually that clear there's
many things he's encountering yeah and
that's another reason that I would I
would call Forrest Gump a sort of an
advanced an advanced craft story right
because it's pretty non-traditional it's
you know you have one guy and I don't
know that I would say he has a very
clear end point that he's working toward
it's a little bit episodic we're sort of
watching him kind of go through history
different notable points in history and
kind of accidentally showing up in the
right place at the wrong time or
whatever
um so that is a that's one of those
stories that I think would be a
difficult one for a newer writer to try
to make work because
if you don't have that sort of like
standard framework of character pursuing
a goal to give you that spine and kind
of that main conflict to rely on then
you have to use other tools in your
toolkit to create enough conflict and
enough engagement to keep us invested
right to keep us engaged in the story
and sort of not checking out and turning
it off so I think Forrest Gump does that
through like you know just the sort of
novelty of the character right like he's
what's that guy going to do next like
where is he going to show up and what
what
um you know famous moment in history are
we going to show it see him pop up in so
I think that's part of the appeal of
that story and then also within within
each kind of little segment of story I
do think that there is conflict it's not
like I'm saying that it has no conflict
but I think it happens you know in sort
of
like instead of happening kind of big
picture across the whole movie if I'm
remembering it correctly it happens more
in self-contained segments and then you
also have these store these like longer
story lines of like his
um love for Jenny right his relationship
for Jenny which weaves in and out of the
other stuff that's happening if if I'm
remembering that right yeah no that's
excellent and and then if you look at
crash which I know we brought up earlier
that is like nothing but conflict yeah
which is the through line of basically
the story that ties
all the characters and different stories
together yeah so that one has so many I
think it has like three or four
intersecting storylines right and each
one has its own sort of main conflict
that we're following
um and then part of the appeal of that
too is seeing how those story lines
intersect because that's kind of the the
point of the story or the concept of it
how can goals of the protagonist and
antagonists oppose each other to create
conflict uh well there's a lot of
different ways
um
I think that you know if you look at if
you look at the movies that you like
you'll you'll probably see that they the
main conflict falls into a few different
categories
um it's not always the same from movie
to movie
um sometimes the protagonist has a goal
and the antagonist is trying to stop
them sometimes the antagonist has a goal
and the protagonist is trying to stop
them
um sometimes they both want the same
thing and so they're competing for you
know a prize or a thing that only one of
them can have
um and then sometimes they just happen
to be you know the protagonist and
antagonist are just two characters who
each have a goal that happen to conflict
with each other so they're getting in
each other's way those are kind of the
ones that I've noticed are the are the
most common versions of that
sure and then if we go back to
bridesmaids that there is it seems like
all of them have a common goal which is
to be accepted amongst their peer group
yeah well if we're talking about the
story goal the more sort of like plot
specific
um thing that the protagonist is trying
to achieve
so it's actually
um the antagonist is Helen which is the
The Rose Burn character right and she
wants to take over our protagonist's
friendship so she's the the Rival for
this best friendship right that Annie
our protagonist has her lifelong best
friend
um so when Annie discovers that
about the Helen character that's when
she forms her goal to stop the
antagonist right so it's just sort of
you know it's a little bit of um it
might sound very technical or very like
Theory heavy but I think these are just
tools that help you understand your own
story and understand how your particular
story works so it's not that I'm I
certainly don't mean that you have four
different types of conflict and you have
to use one of them I think if you you
know if you've come up with an idea that
you're trying to develop
trying to look at it through these four
types of conflict right or these four
kind of like conflict Dynamics
if you can see that your conflict falls
into one of those categories it just
helps you understand like oh okay so if
mine is like this then that means you
know it gives you it gives you a little
bit of guidance in terms of okay so that
means the antagonist has to come up with
their goal first so that then the
protagonist can find out about it and
form her story goal right and that gives
you a little bit of guidance in terms of
like okay so that's the order that
things need to happen in so I can break
down the plot of my movie that way and
it helps you write it so right and it
seems like in some films the antagonist
doesn't really turn out to be the
antagonist at all or maybe that's just
how I'm seeing it and then others it's
clearly that was the antagonist and they
were defeated or they they win whatever
way so Silence of the Lambs we know that
definitely he's the antagonist but in in
Bridesmaids it's kind of not you know
maybe Helen is not totally it's just
that they both had their own sort of
needs and they were just getting in the
way yeah and I think that that you can
look at that too as being like
appropriate to the tone or the style of
what you're writing right because it
might have felt weird if Helen that
antagonist was you know had seriously
kind of like evil designs on Annie and
all that stuff right so the humor in
that keeps it you know that that's also
a guide in terms of like what types of
conflict are going to work in this
um so those two characters you probably
have a little bit more empathy for uh
for Helen than you do for Buffalo Bill
you'd even though you learn why he's
doing what he's doing uh Helen is more
of a real character and the comedy comes
from you know the these kind of like
wacky situations that our protagonist
gets herself into you know sure and we
look at maybe Helen it's more about
vanity and sort of serving her own ego
and yeah but but then you find out that
actually she's very empty and so it's
not it's you feel for her in the end
yeah you want to hate her and then you
realize I don't actually hate you yeah
they do a good job actually of revealing
that she is not sort of the I mean she
is sort of shallow and and focused on
status and and all that through the
movie but they do reveal that she has a
you know an emotional need of her own
she's lonely and she's in an
unfulfilling marriage and so you kind of
end up growing I think to at least feel
for her if not like her more by the end
and she's still the you know when we're
talking about protagonist and antagonist
we're really just talking about like the
mechanics of the story not necessarily
that she needs to feel like a villain or
like a you know an evil character or
even that you can't like her you know
you can like the character who is the
sort of antagonistic Force we're just
talking about the the way the elements
of the story work together to kind of
you know create that that
um story engine or that that
um spine of the story that we were
talking about earlier
I think we spoke about this briefly in
our last interview but what are the four
common ways characters challenge
protagonists oh
um well I usually think about that in
terms of like the supporting characters
that are sort of around you know the
protagonist and again I you know these
are not not limited to four there
certainly could be many other ways but I
think that these are the patterns that
I've noticed
um a lot of times the supporting
characters will sort of help the
protagonist through conflict right like
they create some sort of conflict with
the protagonist
um but that conflict or that pain that
they're bringing into the protagonist's
life is one of those sort of forcing
mechanisms that that force that
protagonist to grow and learn the lesson
that they need to learn right
um so the four that I've noticed are
like
um I think I call them like aspirational
models so giving your conflict or sorry
giving your protagonist
um
a a model of what they would like to do
or like to achieve or like to be and
that can create conflict because it you
know creates a situation where your
protagonist is unhappy with where they
are and they're striving for more
um there's also the cautionary tale so
creating you know creating it's almost
the opposite of the of the other one
where
um it's showing your protagonist what
could happen if they continue down the
road that they're on right so this is
you know sort of like that that side
character in and this is such a minor
minor role but in Crazy Stupid Love that
sad divorced dad at the bar right like
that's a cautionary tale he does not
want to become that guy so he's going to
continue on
striving to be the womanizer that he's
being groomed to be because it's that
that cautionary tale
um it's a reminder to him
um and then there's also uh I forget
what I've labeled them but um you have
sort of the uh Mentor character or the
person that helps your character learn
that they're capable or they have it in
them to do the thing that they're trying
to do
and that doesn't always have to be you
know a nice Mentor it can be someone who
pushes through tough love or through
conflict through challenging your
character but it's but the ultimate
effect is that it's forcing them to grow
and to accept that they are strong
enough capable enough smart enough
whatever
um and then what's the fourth one
actually oh so a new world view oh yeah
so that's challenging the way your
protagonist sees the world right so
um a lot of times the transformation
that your character goes through is is a
is an it starts internally and then it
manifests externally so sometimes
there's a supporting character that
demonstrates the new way of thinking
that maybe ultimately your character
will adopt or it challenges their own
way of thinking enough that they grow
and they make that change that they need
to make to sort of have a new attitude
about the world or A New Perspective a
new life philosophy that that was the
sort of the point of the story right
that was the growth that they needed at
the beginning
yeah so I think in Bridesmaids is
Melissa McCarthy the one scene yeah so
great so she kind of gives her a you
know kick in the pants
um and and does it in a sort of a sweet
tough love way yeah yeah that's a great
scene so she comes in and she's like
what did she say it's something like you
know the world isn't gonna like hand it
to you you have to go out there and take
it the world's telling you it's here to
be taken or something like that I can't
remember the exact words but but yeah
she she gives her that it's very funny
but it's also uh the exact sort of like
tough love message that Annie needs at
that point sure and she's literally on
the couch like you know not just
metaphorically only touch she's on the
couch feeling sorry for herself and
she's kind of I think she picks her up
doesn't she even throw her over her
shoulder or something but yeah and then
with hustle I can't really remember I
feel like there were Mentor characters
that were helping
um the Adam Sandler character yeah well
what's interesting I think in Hustle is
that um you know you don't have to have
a I guess sort of like archetypal Mentor
for this to for this like sort of role
to come into play
um any character or yeah any supporting
character that sort of helps your
protagonist along that you know Arc of
growth right can can fill any of these
roles so what's great about hustle is
those two guys it's really their
relationship they learn from each other
you know so even though they're not like
you know technically what I would call
like a mentor to each other that's not
kind of their role throughout the whole
movie maybe in terms of helping each of
them grow and and sort of get to the
point that they need to be in order to
succeed in the movie they do learn from
each other like the basketball player
learns that you know there's some people
you can rely on you can actually depend
on someone they're going to come through
for you uh and I kind of forget what
Adam Sandler learns from the basketball
player but it's you know I think it's
complementary to that right it's like
um
if you keep trying keep working you can
like you know succeed and not let people
down or something like that so
um talking about that Melissa McCarthy
character quick quick point about that
what's great about that character is
that that speech she gives right to
Annie doesn't come out of the blue so
that was the last thing I wanted to
mention about her was that that
character has that world view from the
beginning so she Melissa McCarthy has
that sort of attitude about you go out
you grab life you you do it you take
what you want or you take the kind of
life you want you know you don't sit
back you don't sit on the couch and like
let it pass you by if you want something
you go out and you try for it if you
fail no big deal if you look like a fool
no big deal but you you have to try in
order to get what you want and so I
think if you know the bad version of
that relationship and that movie would
have been if Melissa McCarthy was just a
nice bridesmaid who came along at the
right moment in the end to tell Annie
what she needed to know right that would
have felt sort of unearned and tacked on
but because we saw that you know we
didn't know where that was going from
the beginning but we saw that that
Melissa McCarthy character was that
person all the way through so when she
delivers that message to Annie right
when she needs it it makes sense it
feels emotionally true you know sure
sure and just going back to hustle real
quick it seems like also too they both
respect each other because they know
their families are very important to
them yeah and so I think they both have
sort of earned that
um and they become almost mentors to
each other yeah in some ways yeah I
think they do they they sort of because
they each go into it I think with
certain preconceived notions about the
other right like our basketball player
thinks that Adam Sandler's just this
Rich American who can kind of like you
know he's got the the wallet of the the
team behind him and he can do whatever
and over time they learn they kind of
learn how desperate each one is but they
learn what's really motivating each of
them and they bond over that right
because they each have a family to like
you said each have a family to support
they learn that they each are kind of
like on their you know this is this is
it this is the last chance that they
have to kind of like make this big thing
happen so as those you know truths are
revealed about each of them it bonds
them it makes them grow closer uh which
helps that sort of like partnership and
help helps them accomplish the thing
yeah
what are Stakes
something that confuses a lot of a lot
of writers it's um so
Stakes are very generally like whatever
hangs in the balance
um with regard to what your character is
trying to achieve so a lot of movies are
very clear external you know life and
death Stakes right if your character
doesn't
um escape the serial killer then they
will die right the your protagonist will
die so then it's life and death Stakes
um so it's whatever consequence would
would come and would come to Bear if
your protagonist fails to achieve their
story goal that's sort of how I would
define it
why are Stakes important uh well I think
Stakes are important because that's
if if there's nothing at stake then the
story doesn't matter right if um if your
protagonist is trying to achieve a thing
but nothing there won't be any
consequence to it then
I don't know if your audience will
remain engaged in the story right
because we we sort of if we if we
understand that a series of events
doesn't matter it doesn't have any
consequence to it it's inconsequential I
think most of us would check out could
be entertaining for a while but
eventually we'll be like okay I you know
I don't really care about the ending of
it so whatever's at stake in the story
is really what sort of gets us to care
about the outcome
yeah and I know again we use hustle as
an example and I think that's what got
the film for me that's why I liked it
I'm not really into sports but the the
stakes that were involved and it was
numerous times yeah that was what was so
great is you thought you got through one
hurdle and then there was another one
presented yeah and I think you know all
of these elements sort of go hand in
hand right they all depend on each other
to kind of create the effect that you
want them to create on the audience so
what's great about hustle is like it
it's not life or death Stakes it's not
that you know high stakes of a of a
movie but you feel so much for that
character that what's important to him
is important to you so that you know
what this career means to him it's the
only thing he's ever done it's what he
loves it's you know what he's dedicated
his whole life to there's the feeling
that if he sort of washes out now his
whole life will be meaningless or you
know he'll have invested all this time
and something that ultimately didn't
matter had no out no uh consequence so
all of that is wrapped up in what's at
stake for him so
what I was describing earlier sort of
the external Stakes of like what's the
consequence that will happen if your
character fails right that's usually in
a movie there's something external at
stake so life and death Stakes or like
somebody's safety or
um you know losing the house or what
have you but then there's also the sort
of internal Stakes of it the emotional
Stakes of it which is really like what
it means to your character so you know
it's important for the Adam Sandler
character to
um achieve that goal because of all that
stuff that it represents to him and
that's that I think is the more
emotional side of things and that's what
really gets us like emotionally invested
in a story you know
right I think there's like one scene in
the beginning or close to it where Adam
Sandler's on the phone with someone he's
like 50 year old guys don't have dreams
we have nightmares and panic attacks
yeah
yeah they do such a good job of like
layering that stuff in right of of just
exactly what does it mean if he fails to
you know get this last career thing
because it would be very easy for that
movie to sort of hit all of the the plot
beats that we expect but to feel empty
right like that would have been the bad
version of that movie of like you know a
near retirement guy has one last chance
to get a player signed and you could see
that playing out in a way that the plot
would make sense but because they went
the extra you know the extra mile in
terms of like developing that character
and what it all meant to him that made
it you know I loved that movie it made
it very emotional for me instead of just
being like oh this is a fun movie about
guys playing basketball it was much more
about the Adam Sandler character and
sort of you know that was like a
Redemption story for him it was like my
life hasn't been a waste I'm not too old
to accomplish things you know all of
those things I think were layered into
that movie and that's what made it
that's what actually I made it a movie
that I would recommend to people versus
one that I watch and forget about you
know and and then without giving away
too much the basketball player has his
own stakes and then you also see that
part of the stakes for Adam Sandler is
proving to the basketball player that
I'm I'm actually not going to let you
down yeah that's what was really great
about that movie too is that
relationship between those two guys so
it's very much an underdog sports movie
and the two of them are sort of the only
you know the only two the only person
that each has in their life that really
believes in them in a way that that sort
of matters and they can help each other
and so there are two underdogs sort of
working together to achieve this big
thing that nobody thinks they can
achieve so yes that that made me root
for them you know what I love that two
underdogs working together that's right
yeah yeah that's what works about it how
do we know the stakes are high enough
for the audience to be emotionally
invested that's a good it's a good
question and I think that's one of those
things that's a little bit
um you know trial and error in your in
your writing you do what you can to
um create the stakes in your story
external and internal
um try to plan them out in a way that
that you feel like will be enough to get
the audience invested but that is
definitely one of those things that you
know in completing the first draft
sometimes you have somebody read it
they're like I don't really understand
why this matters or I don't know why I
should care about this story and then
you know that the stakes aren't coming
through right they may be high enough
but they may just not be conveyed on the
page in a way that the whoever read it
you know can understand why they should
care so there's both the aspect of like
you know planning as you're developing
your story thinking through what's at
stake and why this is going to matter
and what it means to the character and
so that's why the audience will care
about it thinking through all of those
questions and and making sure that's in
your story that's half the battle and
then the other half is actually figuring
out how to put it on the page in a way
that your reader can pick it up right
and can understand and can feel sort of
what's at stake
yeah I think that was what was my
problem with bridesmaids when I heard
about it and it came out and everybody
was raving and I was turning on the
radio and oh Bryce and I'm like oh
another one of these female on female
hating each other and competing I don't
want to see that and it's it's not it's
so well done and there's you you really
see okay no this is there's a lot more
layers to this yeah and actually you
bring you bring up a good point because
seeing Helen come through in the end and
sort of change a little bit and seeing
that she and Annie don't end the movie
totally at odds with each other I think
that that was really important to to the
the sort of you know overall bigger
picture of that movie which was like
it's not about women competing against
each other it's actually about the
female friendship right and so even the
fact that the protagonist and antagonist
can come through the end of this
experience
learning enough about each other to kind
of not hate each other and not be
working against each other that was an
important lesson in the movie too
can you help us understand the
difference between the stakes for the
protagonist and the antagonist oh sure
um I mean I think each character
needs to have something at stake we
probably need to understand what's at
stake for the protagonist a little bit
more right because we're entering the
story through that character and their
experience of it is really what we're
sort of tracking and writing along with
through the entire movie
um so just in general I would say that
you know the protagonist Stakes are
probably going to be more developed
um both externally and internally we're
probably going to spend more time
understanding those Stakes
um establishing them in the movie and
then you know escalating them across the
movie but I do think that the antagonist
should have something at stake as well
otherwise
um I think that's when you get you know
kind of like I mentioned earlier you get
maybe one of those movies that hits
certain plot beats but feels a little
bit empty if we don't understand why the
antagonist is doing what they're doing
as well even if it's in very broad
Strokes you know
um I think it can feel
a little a little empty a little
cartoony or even a little bit sort of
like it doesn't have emotional logic you
know
sure
the movie the the book shop no okay yeah
okay
um it was so good it was with Patricia
Clarkson who's like this sort of wealthy
woman who has started this art Society
in her town and then a new younger woman
comes in and opens up this bookstore and
that causes Patricia Clarkson's standing
in the community like like who is this
and you're doing this in my town I'm
sorry and then the young woman starts to
put these beautiful book displays and
everybody comes in and they love their
books the bookstore and then she does
Lolita the book uh by navikov in the in
the um window and that's Patricia
Clarkson's in and you will not have this
in my town but really her her motive is
you won't show me up that that's really
what it's about and it's so well done
and
um it's it's about this sort of you see
each character's Stakes uh one just
wants to do it because I forgot what the
reason was she needed something in her
life and this gave her joy and then the
Patricia Clarkson it was more about you
know her image and power and yeah the
two the two that uh well you bring up a
good point I haven't seen that movie I
will add it to my list but um but I
think you bring up a good point which is
you know when the conflict is more uh
character based or more sort of like
emotional rather than physical
um I think we probably need to develop
the stakes more right in order to
understand sort of why are these
characters in Conflict why are they
taking the actions that they're taking
whereas if you have something very
external very you know actiony or like
horror movies are often high stakes
they're they're life and death
situations but because it's such an
external physical uh conflict we
understand easily why this is important
right we understand it's a life and
death situation so you don't really have
to explain it as much or develop it as
much it's still useful I think if even
in movies that have very clear you know
external Stakes if you develop the
internal the meaning of it as well right
because that helps us get sort of more
emotionally invested in the story
um but yeah the I think the story that
you brought up that Bookshop is a good
example of having
um you know the conflict is really it's
character based and it's um it's in not
internal but it's um it's not a physical
sort of conflict between the two of them
they have these like
big emotional Stakes for each of them
they're standing in the town or their
reputation or whatever and so you have
to develop those so that the audience
understands what's motivating them to do
the things they're doing because we
don't immediately understand
why someone would you know take those
actions that they're taking in the story
you know
what is the central dramatic question
well the central dramatic question is
just another way to sort of phrase that
idea that your story is about one person
trying to achieve one thing right so
it's again it's another tool to kind of
help you wrap your brain around your own
story
um so whatever your your protagonist is
pursuing their story goal over the
course of that story
um if you if you phrase that as a
question that is the central dramatic
question and then that's the question
that you're trying to answer over the
course of the story right so you know
for for Silence of the Lambs my go-to
example it's it's will Clarice catch the
serial killer
um that's that's the question that we're
waiting for the answer to that the story
is hopefully going to answer by the end
of it otherwise we'll be unsatisfied
what happens when the central dramatic
question is answered
then your movie's basically over so you
know that that gives us that framework
for your story so it's the thing that
we're tracking
um and then once that question is
answered it feels to us like your story
is resolved right so there might be a
little bit of wrap up after that there
might be you know some an emotional
button to put on the story or like a
subplot or something that needs to be
tied up or you might need a scene to
show us sort of what's the character
going to do next where is their life
going from here but pretty much when
that question is answered that's when
the audience feels like ah okay this
this thing that I've been watching is
now coming to an end right like this is
the end of it
well if we look at a lot of let's say
tentpole movies there's probably going
to be a resolution unless there's a
sequel planned and then they want to
kind of keep you hanging but some movies
don't seem like they always answer they
there's a there's a vagueness to them
yeah I don't I don't think an you know a
movie has to answer every question that
it brings up but that Central dramatic
question we want some feeling of
resolution right so I do think that
there are movies that leave it ambiguous
and that's the point
um but I think that it has to be clear
that that is the point right so then we
feel like Okay so this experience of
exploring or trying to get the answer to
this question maybe we couldn't answer
it and that's the point of it and so
that gives you that feeling of even if
the question isn't resolved that story
is resolved because we've gotten to a
point where we're like ah okay so here's
How This Ends we don't know how that
story is you know how that question is
answered
so always know your audience is probably
much smarter than you give them credit
for but then if you end it in too much
of a vague way it may just be that the
writer didn't have a clear view
themselves yeah I think in most cases
um
even if you leave it open if it's a sort
of a you know you don't fully answer the
question or you leave it an ambiguous
ending and that's the point of your
story it has to feel deliberate to your
audience otherwise they will feel like
you didn't do your job right like
they'll sort of feel like you left them
hanging unintentionally and I think you
want you always want your audience to
feel like they're in good hands you want
them to feel like you are you know what
you're doing and you're telling them a
very specific story in a very specific
way and the things that they're feeling
were orchestrated by you you know what I
mean and so even if you don't give them
that like nice tidy neat you know
wrapped up thing in the end they need to
know that that was your choice and not
accidental
what if the writer can't figure out what
the central dramatic question is
um well I I don't think that there's
necessarily like one you know right
answer that you're you have to figure
out exactly what that question is
otherwise your story doesn't work again
it's more of a tool to kind of help you
and give you a framework for your story
and understand what your audience is
um tracking in the story right so it's
kind of a way to get everybody on the
same page
um but I think just thinking about what
is my protagonist trying to achieve by
the end of this
um answering that question of who wants
what in this story and then
um turning that into a question is kind
of the way you get your central dramatic
question so it's knowing what your
audience
sorry it's knowing what you want your
audience to track that's the question
that you're that you're trying to pose
by the end of act one if that makes
sense well can we have examples of
central dramatic questions in different
films sure so
um I think the central dramatic question
in Crazy Stupid Love right would be
um
actually I think in that movie it's it's
something along the lines of like what
kind of guy will Cal decide to be right
it's because he's
kind of at a Crossroads in his life
where he's been asked for a divorce he
doesn't know I think that he even says
like he doesn't know who he is as a
father and as a husband and that's part
of being misguided by the Ryan Gosling
characters Cal's at a loss he's sort of
adrift and he doesn't know which
direction to go now that his life as he
knows it is sort of ending
um and so I think that if I'm
remembering it right the central
dramatic question in that movie is like
what kind of what kind of guy will cat
or what kind of man will Cal choose to
be and so we see him kind of navigate
that question over the course of the
movie right like he sort of gets taken
One Direction by Ryan Gosling and then
around the middle of the movie he
realizes oh this isn't you know this
isn't who I want to be or this isn't
doing any favors it's not getting me the
thing that I ultimately want which is my
wife
um
so again I'm not 100 sure that I'm
remembering that movie correctly but I
think that you could look at it that way
that that's the question where we're
sort of waiting for him to answer by the
end of it
sure and and can he still be a good guy
despite bad things happening to him and
show that at the core he's actually a
great person yeah and it's part of his
character Arc too right of choosing like
ultimately the lesson I think that he
learns in that movie is the thing that
he says when he stands up in front of uh
his son's middle school graduation where
he's like when you find the one you
don't give up you keep fighting for them
right so that's the kind of guy that
he's decided he's going to be by the end
of the movie is he's you know he's not
going to be this womanizer who goes out
and sleeps with every woman he can he
knows who he's in love with he knows
what he wants is to you know to have
that relationship and so he's just gonna
keep trying so even if you don't know
the outcome you keep trying for the one
that you that you really love right so
that's kind of the lesson that he learns
at the end of it and then for Silence of
the Lambs yeah so that one's a lot more
straightforward you have a nice clear
external goal in that one
um so the central dramatic question
there is is Will Clarice catch the
serial killer right because that's
everything that's set up and give the
context that we're given in act one is
like you have Clarice you have a serial
killer on the loose uh she's the only
one or she's she's one person who has
sort of a special in to get help to
catch that serial killer so that's the
goal that's formed by the end of act one
is like I'm going to try to catch that
serial killer so if we just turn that
into a question it's will she catch that
serial killer and that is what the
audience is watching and waiting for the
answer to
and then to go back to the Forrest Gump
example I know we're using it a lot but
that one it seems like there that's a
little unclear to me yeah and and again
I haven't seen that movie in so long
that I'm not 100 sure on how everything
plays out in it but it does feel to me
like that is a much more episodic story
um I wonder if I re-watched it if and
again you know there are moments that I
remember out of it but I don't remember
the whole story I wonder if the Jenny
relationship is actually kind of the
spine of that story
um and so it could be
again I'd be guessing but it could be
that the the central dramatic question
has something to do with whether he'll
have a relationship with her but again
I'm not 100 sure on that one why do you
put the central dramatic question in
between act one and act two oh well you
know if we look at sort of the the basic
structure of a movie you know we
typically talk about it in three-act
structure and that's really just
um
how the pursuit of the goal breaks down
so in act one because really the the
story of your movie is the story of this
the goal and the pursuit of this goal
right like that's what creates the
through line in your story so act one
that goal is created act two the goal is
pursued and then act three it's resolved
or not right so they get the goal or
they don't so that the central dramatic
question is basically by the end of act
one we have all of the context that we
need in order to understand what the
protagonist is trying to do and what
they're trying to do is answering that
question so that's why the central
dramatic question is sort of solidified
or asked for the audience at the end of
act one and then the meat of the movie
is watching them try to answer it across
act two and act three
what is the purpose of act one
well act one gives us all of the context
that we need in order to understand the
story that we're about to watch
um and understand you know it basically
sets up the who wants what of of your
movie so you know if we look at each
movie as being a story of someone wants
something uh
wants it badly you know goes after
against big conflict great opposition
um then act one sets up all of those
pieces right so it tells us who it tells
us what they want it tells us why they
want it and it tells us what they're up
against
so all of those pieces that sort of
create
the foundation of the story or that like
story engine that we were talking about
earlier that's what act one does it sets
up all of those things so that when we
launch into Act 2 or that like act 2
Adventure you might have heard it called
when we begin that we have all of the
information that we need in order to
understand who are we watching what are
they trying to do what are they up
against
um you know why do they want it so badly
like all of that's been established so
that we can just watch everything
escalate in act two does that make sense
it does and so as we talked about
earlier a lot of people have a great
idea and maybe the act one is really
strong but then subsequent acts seems
like it's very murky and that's where
the outline would help them yeah and I
think um just knowing that you know act
one is is sort of set up it's where you
set up all of that context
um and then understanding that act 2 is
escalation so you have all those pieces
in place in act one and then act two is
just playing with them and sort of
forcing them to butt up against each
other and create you know bigger and
bigger conflicts and higher and higher
Stakes that's where you know that's the
fun of act two is watching how
everything that you've set up in Act One
watching how that blossoms now you know
how or explodes
what mistakes do writers often make in
Act One
um well I think the the probably you
know big bucket maybe a lot of different
things fall into this but the the main
thing is
um not setting up all of the context
that we need right so not clearly
establishing those those Foundation
pieces of the story those you know main
elements that we need to understand and
appreciate act two so it's the
protagonist it's their story goal it's
where the conflict is coming from that
main conflict or the antagonist and it's
the main thing that's at stake for the
protagonist right so all of those pieces
have to be in place in act one and when
um when they're not properly established
I mean I think that's the that's the
most common kind of mistake that that
writers make in act one
what mistakes do writers make in act two
oh Act 2 is so wide open right it's it's
the escalation of your story and it's
watching the thing that you've set up
it's watching it play out but it can go
in so many different directions right
um I think maybe if I had to name one
thing probably the biggest would mistake
would be no I have to I have to do too
so the first one is uh not having their
protagonist pursue the goal consistently
and urgently right because that's really
what moves your story forward is the
protagonist trying to achieve that thing
um so that's a big one and then I would
say maybe the other big one and this is
kind of connected is not escalating
things so sort of hitting the same note
over and over
um not intensifying the conflict not
raising the stakes because we want
things to to grow right we want the
conflict to sort of double back on
itself and compound and things to get
harder and more intense and to feel more
important and more urgent for the
protagonist that's you know the
progression of act two should should
have that sort of
um building feeling to it and so I think
that's probably the other the other big
one is maybe hitting the same the same
intensity level or re
you know reworking the same conflict
without making things harder or making
things more important or urgent yeah
that was the great thing about hustle is
that so many new things came up without
spoiling it for those who haven't seen
it once you got through one hurdle a new
one was presented yeah and it's really
not even until the end where I mean
you're like this can't end this way but
anyway yeah and that was you know they
they did such a good job of having
conflict come from so many different
directions too right it wasn't just that
this is a difficult thing to achieve and
so it's you know Adam Sandler trying to
get the basketball player in shape or
you know ready to compete at this level
you had other players with their own
agendas you had you know uh the like we
talked about the owner has his own
agenda you know things going wrong so
you had conflict coming from all these
different directions which is great
because again growing the intensity
across act two right that's what keeps
you sort of like leaning in over and
over again going like oh no what's gonna
happen now what's what could possibly go
worse for this character and and that
keeps you kind of like reinvesting in
the outcome I don't know if you've seen
did you watch the series made oh
absolutely yes yes so that is such a
good example just even the first episode
of that series is such a good example of
conflict and building conflict and
nothing going right for the protagonist
like you know one of the comments I
think that writers hear a lot is like
things are too easy for your protagonist
or you know you need to increase the
conflict or make things hard put your
character through hell right like those
are all kind of tidbits of advice that
writers hear but I feel like you know
writers
um like their characters sometimes and
don't want to make things too hard or or
don't see a way for the character to get
through it if they make things too hard
um but that that first episode of made
was such a good example of like nothing
went right for that character every
single thing went wrong and she still
you know I mean that's kind of the point
is like that makes us root for her even
more because it everything's stacked
against her and we're we're on board
we're watching we want her to succeed so
I don't think you can ever make things
too hard for your protagonist right and
and that was one of the things in
listening to the audiobook that it was
based on it was so like I felt so bad
for this woman and and hearing it and
then I guess it was just easier for me
to watch it
um
sort of play out and and I don't know it
was still difficult but yes I mean it
was so many different things being set
up I don't want to give that away but
yeah I absolutely love that yeah I think
that's a great one for writers to watch
if if you ever you've ever gotten the
note of like you're not making things
hard enough on your character you know
watch that and see just how hard you can
you can be on your character without
breaking them you know because I think
maybe that's what scares writers is like
if I make things too hard I won't be
able to figure out how they're gonna
keep going or I won't be able to figure
out kind of like how to get them through
it but that you know dialing up that
intensity is is good it's good for your
story and that's kind of what your
audience wants you know
sure and she would have these meltdowns
and then she would kind of get back on
the horse and then new things would
happen yeah and we like her more for
that too for not giving up you know so
right yeah she was very likable yeah as
a character what is the purpose of act
three well act three is to resolve that
question that you've asked or that main
conflict that you've sort of put your
character into
um so it's really it's to resolve the
the question that we've been exploring
over the over the course of the movie
right
um when you uh set up all those pieces
that we talked about in act one all of
the foundation pieces of your story and
then we watch them play out across act
two
um act three is where you answer that
Central dramatic question wrap up your
story resolve that conflict if you want
to think of it that way it's it's
basically basically The Resolution Act
that's you know you've done all the
escalations and there will still be some
escalations in act three but it's
building toward uh resolving your your
main conflict and answering that Central
dramatic question
what mistakes do writers make most often
in act three uh well I think the big one
maybe the most obvious one would be just
not resolving that you know Central
dramatic question or that main conflict
that we're we're you know we're watching
the movie to understand how that's going
to wrap up and so I think
um not resolving that is is maybe the
the biggest or the most common sort of
like newer writer mistake
um sometimes sometimes newer writers
um you know again out of fear maybe that
their story is getting boring or they
don't know how to how to escalate it and
don't know where to go from here they
they take a left turn and start
tracking a different question or a
different conflict that their
protagonist engages in and we really
want act three to sort of like complete
that through line not take such a hard
left that we're now watching a different
movie you know
and does that often we you know sort of
see comments um underneath the trailer
oh the trailer is better than the movie
is it often the act three do you think
or the act two or there's no hard and
fast rule yeah I wonder I I don't know
for sure but I would I would guess that
maybe
um a really good trailer was cut from
from a movie that didn't have as much
going on in act two and probably act
three as well but since Act 2 is really
kind of like the movie you know that's
what the movie is it's the character
trying to do this thing it's conflict
escalating it's Stakes raising that's
really the you know act two and that is
the movie that we're we're there to see
so I would imagine if if a trailer or if
a movie is getting those comments and
like the trailer was so much better than
the movie The Good interesting or
entertaining moments were cut into the
trailer and maybe there just wasn't
enough going on in the movie to sustain
interest or you know to to maintain our
our investment in the outcome of it
why is transformation of the main
character important uh well I think we
go to movies really to see
transformation right
um transformation means that the story
had an effect it the series of events
that you've watched it had some sort of
consequence it had an effect on the
character that went through them so
that's one reason and then I think also
you know even if nobody talks about it
this way we sort of we look for that
transformation as like
um sort of a inspiration or you could
call it a guide for for living a good
life right like it's this person went
through this experience and sort of came
out the other side uh can give you hope
it can give you a little bit of
um you know a guide a guide on how to
live and be a better person but that's
kind of like what gives the story
meaning in the end you know how does
transformation relate to theme well I
think that most often we see the theme
of the movie through the character's
transformation so whatever that lesson
is that they learn from going through
this whole experience that's basically
the theme of your movie
um you know
the the theme is like the sort of
organizing principle of your story right
and everything connects to the theme and
kind of everything falls under the
umbrella of the theme and the way your
movie plays out proves the theme to the
audience and so a big part of that is
the way the protagonist goes through the
story and what happens to them how they
transform because of what they've gone
through so we see the theme the meaning
or that takeaway message of the story we
see that through the way the character
transforms most often
for some reason I'm thinking of like
Goodwill Hunting just popped into my
mind it's been many years since I've
seen it yeah the transformation of that
character yeah and kind of the theme
would be what just sort of I know you
said host earlier yeah well I think that
it themes
um tend to fall into like a couple of
categories or patterns right um one of
them can be sort of Hope for
um living right
um and then another kind of category I
think is like there's Beauty in the
struggle right like themes kind of fall
into these different categories but
specific themes for particular movies
um most often I look to the characters
transformation or the lesson that they
learn to kind of understand what the
theme is
um in Goodwill Hunting it's been a while
since I saw that movie but uh I guess
let's see how does he transform from the
beginning to the end well so he's he's
angry he gets in fights he's got this
job that you know he's kind of looked
down on a pawn but he's definitely
smarter than and maybe some of the
students around him there and he
[Music]
um
meets a girl yeah I was gonna say I
think the lesson has to do with that big
choice that he makes at the end right so
he he sort of learns over the course of
this story that he's not doing himself
or anyone else any favors by not living
up to his potential right
um again it's been a while since I saw
the movie so hopefully that's accurate
but um but I would say that you know
that if you look at his transformation
and sort of the key lesson that he needs
to learn or that he does learn by the
end of that story then that's kind of
the key to your theme I would say that
that lesson is basically the theme you
could reword it a little bit and then if
if that's accurate say for for Goodwill
Hunting if the lesson that he learns is
um you know life is about living up to
your potential for example I don't know
if that's true but we'll say that that's
the lesson he learns in Good Will
Hunting uh I would say that the theme of
the movie would be very close to that so
the overall message that that story
would send that you would maybe walk
away from the movie understanding is
living up to your potential is what
life's about or it's how to live a good
life is to to try to you know strive to
live up to your potential or what have
you what does the audience need to see
in each Act in order to understand the
protagonist transformation oh well um I
think the the transformation has you
know
it has an arc of its own so in the same
way that like the plot has a setup and a
build and a resolution I think the
characters Arc also has those those
parts so in act one we need to set up
that Arc by understanding what the
character needs right like what is their
deficit or what lesson do they need in
their life
um what sort of are they doing wrong or
how are they seeing the world in a way
that's not serving them and what effect
is it having on their life so we need to
see that they need a lesson and we need
to see sort of we need to understand
that they do need it and usually that's
by seeing some sort of negative effect
that not understanding that lesson is
having on their life right and then in
act two that's where we see kind of the
the the story of this Arc play out so we
need to see the things that he the
protagonist experiences in the story
sort of forcing him along that growth
Arc forcing him to realize the lesson
that he needs to get closer to accepting
it or to
um maybe the character is resisting
learning this lesson and the things that
he's going through are forcing him
closer and closer to kind of that
breaking point where he's going to
finally understand what he needs to
learn from this whole this whole mess
right
um so act two forces the the plot events
and the experiences that the character
has
forces him sort of closer to
understanding the lesson
that thematic lesson right and then in
act three that's where we get to see the
character
Embrace this lesson or not right in most
movies that we watch that have sort of
um Transformed Characters and Happier
Endings usually they accept the lesson
and embrace it and incorporate it into
the way they approach the world and then
that's that's how we see that Arc
resolve how does character lead to plot
oh well I think you can you can use
character to sort of lead you to figure
out plot by
related to character Arc right so
understanding
what lesson your character might need to
learn or what transformation you want
this character to have right
um this is sort of coming at it from a
like a meaning point of view instead of
an external plot point of view so coming
kind of from inside the story to figure
out the plot so if you start with
character and you think about what
lesson do I want this character to learn
or what transformation can I imagine
this character going through that
interests me that can lead you to plot
because you know that the plot that they
experience needs to sort of create that
change in the character right those
events have to force that character to
learn that lesson so you can sort of
reverse engineer the plot from the
transformation that the character is
going through
um thinking about okay here's the
transformation that interests me I'm I'm
curious about a character who maybe goes
from being um you know an independent
single guy who's determined not to have
any any ties or or serious relationships
to being someone who is is committed and
you know surrounded by close
relationships with friends and family
right so that's his transformation just
for example
um if you're interested in a character
that makes that transformation then you
can reverse engineer the plot to think
about like well what kind of events
would force somebody to make that change
to learn that lesson and sort of
transform in that way
do you see that from time to time with
new writers that there's not a real
lesson
that that's that's learned with their
character and then having to go back and
rework it yeah I I do because I think
that
um not all not all the time but a lot of
uh newer writers and not even newer
writers a lot of Writers come that story
from interesting plot right from
interesting what if uh situations that
are cool or fun
um and then you know developing the
character to go to go along with it and
there's certainly nothing wrong with
that I I think about story in that way
too A lot of the time
um but I think for newer writers then
the challenge is understanding that the
the transformation or the character
development side of the story is is
still needed is important right
um and you know we talked about earlier
that like writing a screenplay is really
getting a handle on lots of different
skills it's a bunch of different skill
sets that you sort of have to employ all
at the same time and I think character
development tends to be
one that maybe
um not for not as forgotten but gets
pushed to the side because you know the
plot is the thing that you know you need
to have right in order for your story to
for your movie to begin and eventually
end you know that you have to sort of
like work out the steps of the plot
um but character you can have characters
show up on the page and go through this
plot without making a change right and
you've still written you can still write
a complete screenplay that way right
um so then that's like another skill set
to master I think or to to learn about
um and so yes with newer writers I think
a lot of times uh not not even a lot of
times but often you'll see
a complete story and the story is there
um and maybe they know that the
character should learn something across
the the course of the story but they
haven't fully you know gotten every step
of that transformation kind of worked
out in there
sure so maybe too worried about just how
the overall story is and then not really
seeing this change in the character at
the end yeah and I think that for
um you know again because it's so many
skill sets it's it's not even
it's it's certainly not deliberate of
like oh I'm not going to worry about
character and it's also not
um I guess it's a very easy thing
because you're trying to juggle so many
moving Parts when you write a screenplay
that
um it's I totally understand
and not not maybe doing all of the
character development up front that you
could right so it's just part of the
rewrite process like you you go through
it many times and then hopefully you get
the character there too yeah hence the
second set of eyes yeah yeah exactly you
said there's so many skill sets to
writing a screenplay can you just
clarify what some of those skill sets
are yeah I just think you know it's we
usually think about writing a screenplay
as just it's just one thing it's one
story that I'm putting down on paper but
you know when you when you try to write
a screenplay well you probably
eventually realize that there's
understanding structure there's
understanding plot and how to escalate
conflict there's understanding character
and character development uh theme and
how theme works with transformation
right and that's just kind of like big
stuff and then you also think about like
the on the page craft writing action
lines well writing dialogue well you
know like there's all these little not
little but there are all these different
skill sets that go into making a really
good screenplay
um and I think it's a lot more than
writers realize maybe at first when they
come at writing a script because you you
sort of you have an idea and you love
your story idea and you start putting it
down on paper and that's great I think
that's the way
you know the best way to learn is to
through experience and through trying it
um but eventually I think you know
anyone who's written a script or two
sort of realizes oh this is this is
harder than I realized it was going to
be because there are so many different
things that I have to be good at in
order to make the whole thing good you
know so if someone just erases a
paragraph
on page 68 it's going to change things
maybe you know on page 10 that they
didn't oh wait a minute I just realized
if I do that that's a major thing I have
to then go back yeah for sure
everything's interdependent
um and I think also you know this is
what this is what makes the rewriting
process so fun and so challenging is
that because
you can be good at one thing or have one
thing kind of figured out one area one
skill set or whatever
um worked out and still be struggling
with other areas and because they're
related you know they they will probably
affect each other
or you know
a lot of times like we were just talking
about character gets sort of
short-shrift you know while we're trying
to work out the plot because we're
there's so much to think about in how do
I structure this plot and how do I
escalate the conflict and how do I make
sure that there it's logical from
beginning to end you know
um and so then in the rewrite you're
gonna have to bring that character
development kind of to the front of your
mind and pay attention to it as you're
rewriting it but yes everything's
interdependent and I think
um even when you have like
some of those skill sets really worked
out you you know the plot's great or
whatever when one of them isn't working
like say the character development or
say the dialogue you just haven't paid
attention to and it needs a lot of work
um
you know it it just it sort of you
realize how much work goes into a
screenplay how many different skill sets
you need in order to complete that thing
in a way that like can be appreciated as
a whole you know
can you explain the Blake Snyder beat
sheet sure so um Blake came up with this
idea of you know sort of the 15 beats
that make up any story
um he put them on a beat sheet it's
become famous now for is a great tool
for people who are developing a story
idea I think or trying to learn about
story structure
um so the one I will say the one thing
that I think people who are introduced
to the beat sheet maybe Overlook and
then have to learn later so this is a
shortcut is that some of the beats are
turning points and then some of the
beats are sections of the story so I'll
I'll go over them
um but it's useful to note that because
I think that's one of the things that
confuses people when they're trying to
learn about the 15 Beats
um okay so the opening image is sort of
the first image of your screenplay or of
your movie it sets the tone
um kind of establishes when and where we
are
um in the world right
um so the world of your story the next
beat that shows up on the beat sheet is
the theme stated and
um Blake wrote in save the cat I think
the theme stated shows up on page five
of your screenplay
um it's you know the theme is usually
the sort of like guiding principle or
the the big idea of the story what it's
really about kind of behind the plot and
behind the characters right
um and he liked to say that it was
stated somewhere in the story or you
know on page five of your screenplay it
was stated outright usually in a line of
dialogue by one of the characters
um the next beat on the um on the beat
sheet is the setup and that's one of
those beats to pay attention to because
the setup is actually a section of the
screenplay right so it's not just one
page or one scene it's a whole section
um I think he notes that it the setup is
like page one to page 12 or so
um and so that's introducing us to the
main character and with their Ordinary
World or their normal World sort of
where they are in their life right now
um before the story gets started right
and one of the things he wrote about in
save the cat was that um you can kind of
use the idea of at home at work and at
play to introduce your protagonist so
seeing them in these different sort of
aspects of their their normal World
gives us a sense of who they are the
next beat on the beat sheet is the
Catalyst and that is a beat that should
be
um more of a turning point like one
scene or One Moment In Your screenplay
um the catalyst is also something that
other people refer to as the inciting
incident it's really the event that
kicks the story into motion
um sometimes you can think of it as the
why now of the story it's this event
sort of you know throws your protagonist
world into disarray or forces them into
action by creating some sort of problem
or opportunity for them that they have
to take advantage of that they have to
deal with right and that's how it starts
the story into motion
the next beat is the debate section and
again it's a it's a section of the
screenplay so this isn't just one scene
um I keep emphasizing that because I've
seen writers get confused and when
they're trying to outline their stories
they get to like the debate section and
they they put in one scene and then when
they go to write the screenplay they
don't have enough story to sort of fill
out the pages right
um so the debate section is where is
that section in between the Catalyst or
the inciting incident sort of kicking
the story into motion and your
protagonist deciding what to do about it
so there's that debate section in
between there
where we really um
try to sort of close all of the obvious
doors for your protagonist and funnel
them toward this main thing that they're
going to do over the course of the story
right uh I also like to look at the
debate section as um getting the
audience on board so you kind of tell us
what's at stake for the protagonist why
they have to do this thing because
usually the thing that they're going to
do in act two is this big audacious
crazy scary dangerous thing right so the
debate section use that to get the
audience on board and show us why do
they need to do this thing why is it so
important what happens if they don't do
it help us understand what the potential
consequences are so that we have that
tension of like wanting them to do it
but being a little bit worried about
them right before they go into act two
uh so the next beat is the break into
act 2. so at the end of the debate
section after you've gone through all of
that gotten the audience on board shown
us why the character has to do this
thing the break and act 2 is the turn in
your plot where you send the protagonist
into Act 2 onto that Main Adventure
pursuing that story goal engaging in the
main conflict however you want to look
at it that's where that's what the break
into Act 2 does
the next section is the
B story then the next beat is the is the
B story so
um Blake liked to say that you know sort
of after that main or that after that
major plot point of the break into act
two
um it was a good time to give your
protagonist and your audience a little
bit of a breather and introduce a
subplot
um he talked about the B story being
sort of the relationship or the subplot
where your character could discuss
learning the theme
um so a lot of times it'll be you know
it might be a romance or it might be a
friendship or something but it's giving
your character an opportunity to talk
about what he's learning talk about what
he's going through and what he's
learning from it
the next uh beat on the beat sheet is
fun and games and again this is a
section of the story so uh the fun and
games is actually on the beat sheet it's
all of the first half of act two right
so it's it's basically everything after
the break into two up until the midpoint
which we'll get to in a sec but so the
fun and games uh Blake wrote that it was
the is where we see the promise of the
premise so um whatever the concept is of
your story the thing that's hooky and
intriguing about you know this story
that's where we see it sort of come to
fruition is in the fun and game so
um I think his famous examples are Liar
Liar it's where we see Jim Carrey
getting used to not being able to tell a
lie uh or in Legally Blonde it's where
we see L getting acclimated to Harvard
Law and she's very much a fish out of
water
um so that's fun in game stuff you can
also think of it as trailer moments
right
um those those very entertaining and
very like sort of on concept moments or
scenes that you would probably cut into
a trailer to show somebody what's so
entertaining about your movie
um
the next beat is the midpoint so that's
you know the middle of your story
um the midpoint is a is a
more of a moment or a scene instead of a
section so again just making that
distinction but the midpoint can be a
few scenes in a row right it's not
really a section of your screenplay but
it can be a sequence because usually
it's a big set piece or like an action
sequence or something that is a little
bit bigger than other scenes right and
really the function of the midpoint is
to increase the opposition and or raise
the stakes of your story so basically
what it comes down to is the midpoint is
increasing the tension in your story to
sort of give it more momentum to get
through the second half right so
sometimes it turns the story in an
entirely New Direction but doesn't
always have to
um in any case what it does is it it
increases sort of that that tension
feeling so that it's sort of like you
know winding up a toy and letting it go
so it gives us that extra momentum and
energy to get through the second half of
the story then after the midpoint the
next beat on the beat sheet is the bad
guys close in so Blake liked to say that
this is sort of where
um things really start going wrong for
your protagonist right so uh you can
have both external and internal bad guys
so it can be plot stuff is going wrong
the literal bad guys can be closing in
you know getting closer gaining on your
protagonist but it can also be
um emotional stuff they're really
struggling with what they're doing they
feel like they can't succeed and maybe
they're having a crisis of Faith or of
confidence
um
and then you can also have conflict
within the protagonist team so that's
also causing things to fall apart right
and basically the bad guys close in
section is leading us sort of downhill
towards the next couple of Beats which
are the
um All Is Lost and Dark Night of the
Soul Beats and these are separate beats
on the beat sheet but I sort of like to
talk about them together because they
really are complementary and they work
together to kind of create that low
point at the end of act two
um so I I sort of like to think of them
as one is
um more external or plot focused and one
is more internal or character focused uh
the All Is Lost is
um usually the sort of what I think of
as the plot focused one right where it's
it looks like the character the
protagonist is not going to succeed it
you might think of it as he's you know
as far away from his goal as he'll ever
be or he feels like he's failing he
feels like there's no hope he doesn't
know how he's going to keep going on and
try to get that goal
um and then the Dark Knight of the soul
is sort of the emotional reaction to
that
um other things that can happen at the
All Is Lost can be like the death of a
mentor I think this is where uh Blake
wrote that there's like that whiff of
death right so it can be the loss or
death of a mentor or of a friend or of a
support system
um it can be a major setback like
um you know being exposed to the bad guy
so now they know who who they're up
against or it can be like losing an
advantage you know but you want it to be
pretty big because we're talking about
kind of the big turning points of the
story
um and then the darkener the soul is the
emotional reaction to that right so it's
now that this big setback has happened
or it looks like I'm not going to be
able to achieve my goal
the protagonist sort of sitting in that
for a moment and wondering what do I do
from here
and a lot of times that's where they
have kind of a glimmer of
I finally understand the lesson of the
theme I finally understand what I should
be learning from this experience
um
they they're not always ready to embrace
that lesson at that point yet right but
they're starting to understand like oh
this is what all of this has been trying
to teach me
um and then after that the next beat is
the break into Act 3.
um so that's the major turning point
where we go from Act 2 to act three and
um basically it's the beginning of the
resolution section of the story right so
that turn you usually want it to feel
like it's sort of pushing us in a new
direction that is toward however the
story is going to resolve right so your
character your protagonist might have a
new plan so after that Dark Night of the
Soul moment they might have a moment of
inspiration where they're like oh okay
now I know what I what I need to do I
now I know how to defeat this bad guy
and so the break into three is where
they begin that that final push to
resolve that story right that main
conflict or
um you know however you want to think
about that that story so the next beat
on the beat sheet after the break into
act 3 is the finale and this is the
section that most people forget is a
section of the story instead of
um one scene right so your finale or the
way Blake wrote about the finale
um is that the finale was all of act
three so it's what you would call the
resolution right or he called it the
finale
um
so this is where we see that new plan
that your protagonist has play out or we
see them execute that that final push
toward trying to resolve the main
conflict
um so finale all of act three
um I think that is that is that beat 14
and then there's 15 is the final image
okay so the last beat on the beat sheet
is the final image so that's after the
finale has played out we've seen how the
main conflict has resolved we've seen if
the protagonist has you know achieved
his goal if they've succeeded or failed
how the out you know how the story
um ends basically like what is the final
outcome and then we have the very last
beat which is the final image which sort
of is that you know you might think of
it as like almost the aftermath of the
of the finale it's now that the story is
over give us one kind of final scene or
image or moment to kind of send the
audience out feeling how you want them
to feel
um knowing maybe what the character is
going to do next or
um you know if you need to sort of
recalibrate the the emotion at the end
of your story maybe the maybe the um the
end of the finale was a big action
sequence and you want to leave us
feeling like knowing that your
protagonist is okay and he won and he's
safe and he's you know rested and not
injured anymore or something like that
the final image can can do that
um Blake also liked to write that it was
uh the final image is like a bookend for
the opening image right so you know I
think
um some people look at it as you want
the the change or the contrast between
the opening image and the final image to
be big enough to sort of uh show that
there was a transformation in that in
that story right so we went from point A
to point Z and there's a big enough
contrast there that we can see this
story you know covered some ground and
had some consequence to it if that makes
sense